bonjour nicolas vidal bonjour olivier
heureux de vous retrouver ce matin dans
la matinale de rtl france alors comment
est ce que vous percevez la polémique
autour de renaud muselier chez les
républicains
alors on va commencer simple il vient
chez les républicains ça sent le sapin
la sphère renaud muselier vous l'avais
dit à i begin des chats sur la
cacophonie qui règne en ce moment chez
les républicains
mais plus largement sur l' état de mort
cérébrale dans laquelle se trouve la
droite française à un an de la
présidentielle
renommé qui ont acquis ce qui est
savoureux c'est que sur la carte ils ont
appelé ça tan rouge sur son lit de camp
républicain à la soupe tiède
ça donne envie j jean castex semble
avoir du temps libre
ces derniers jours id allemand a donc
qui se lit un accord avec renault
mulliez l'a annoncé publiquement
dimanche dans le branle bas de combat
chez les républicains
christian jacob maréchal courage de la
droite chamallows a organisé à la va
vite une réunion au siège du parti pour
apaiser la situation et ils ont appelé
ça en tenant des bouquets aux digues un
peu un mythe et stratégies en pratiquant
la renier de l'euphémisme politique
résultat des courses on s'est entendu
pour hilti l'implosion de vous
l'avez bien mais c'est un épiphénomène
en réalité car les républicains ont déjà
fait naufrage sur les rives du néant
politique olivier et nicolas est ce que
vous pensez que cette polémique donc au
tour de renaud muselier
elle préfigure d'un problème plus
profond dans les mois à venir
ah oui très clairement la politique
autour de renaud muselier et la partie
immergée finalement du très gros
icebergs dans lequel se sont encastrées
les républicains depuis 2007 et
l'élection de nicolas sarkozy
et nous allons essayer ce matin de
comprendre ça en deux points majeurs
première les membres réponse
l'élection de nicolas sarkozy en 2010
cette marque le mariage en grande pompe
finalement de la droite française au
néolibéralisme et sans reniement au
gaullisme donc donc à la souveraineté
rappelez-vous le traité de lisbonne en
décembre 2
17 qui fait 2007 par n'ont que faire
ratifier nicolas sarkozy début 2008 au
congrès de versailles
malgré le non au référendum 2 55% des
français en 2005
si on fait le péché originel cette
droite qui s'est coupé progressivement
désintérêt des français et qui veut
oublier la france encore aujourd'hui un
aucun des cas site des républicains ne
remet en causé de trahison politique et
ne se hasardera encore moins à proposer
quoi d'un nouveau référendum bien
entendu aucun cadre des républicains dlr
ne souhaite aussi engager un changement
de politique économique qui ré contre le
diktat bruxellois il je rappelle à
toutes fins utiles pour nos
téléspectateurs que le candidat françois
fillon avait lui aussi entre autres la
réforme des retraites dans son classeur
voulue par l'union européenne finalement
la droite des garagistes cette
expression chère à william abitbol
conseillant son temps de charles pasqua
est devenu quoi elle est devenue la
droite des mondialistes et au jeu de la
mondialisation emmanuel macron il est le
meilleur
il a d'ailleurs déjà enterré depuis un
certain temps les socialistes et il a
ramené également on le sait dans son
escarcelle plusieurs figures des
républicains qui partagent la même
vision de ce pays et pour ceux et pour
ceux qui font de la résistance au sein
des républicains ils ne parviendront
jamais à pont à un programme politique
qui tranchera avec celui d' emmanuel
macron car l'idéologie est sensiblement
la même pour ne pas dire la même
deuxième élément de réponse battu en
sept ans nicolas sarkozy rappelez-vous
mini de l'intérieur de 2005 à 2007 est
présent la république finalement il a
sapé les fondements sécuritaire avec des
promesses non tenues notamment sur
l'ordre public
l'identité la nation qui ont
profondément déçu les français durant
son quinquennat sarkozy saborde
allègrement l'arrière boutique de la
question sécuritaire et qu'est-ce qu'il
se passe mais est ce parce que marine le
pen se fera sur l'occasion et
mécaniquement la fameuse droite
républicaine en guise de nier son roja
lamentablement donc les républicains
donc donc que rien à proposer si ce
n'est le front républicain avec lequel
on nous rabat les oreilles et le barrage
aura somme nationale qu'il invoque à
tout bout de champ pour masquer le vide
et 2
logique dont ils sont les principales
victimes olivier alors quelles
pourraient être les conséquences chez
les républicains pour 2022 selon vous l
affaire muselier en fait un signe
supplémentaire rien qui étendent une
droite qui est en train de se désagréger
littéralement et de pourrir sur pied
avec un christian jacob qui ne semble
pas taillé pour reconstruire son parti
imposer une politique nationale très
claire carré en réalité entre les
candidats républicains et ceux de la
reine il n'y a pas la venue de longchamp
sur les grandes questions pour l'avenir
de la france et les français
depuis nicolas sarkozy nous l'avons vu
est le fameux traité lisbonne nom bien
compris c'est la chronique politique
d'un naufrage annoncé le parti des as
l'air finalement c'est un quarteron de
mondialiste qui ne s'assume pas et qui
pourrait prendre une très grosse raclée
à la présidentielle alors que reste-t-il
va se poser la question que reste-t-il
aux républicains jusqu'au matin du
premier tour la guerre des ego quelques
questions sociétales çà et là éparpillés
et deux jolies ritournelles sur les
valeurs républicaines à longueur à
longueur de journée sur tous les
plateaux médias car finalement lorsque
vos convictions la texture d'un tuyau
d'arrosage
il est difficile de garder la ligne et
de prétendre à autre chose que d'arroser
les chrysanthèmes de votre propre tombe
politique
alors il nous reste un peu de temps
nicolas on imagine aussi que la question
de la sécurité
elle va s'inviter très fortement dans
cette cette campagne puisque ces
dernières heures il y eut ce drame à
avignon un policier tué donc hier lors
d'une opération de police anti-drogue la
lutte contre le trafic de drogue c'était
une priorité d'ailleurs qui avait été
affichée à montpellier on se souvient
par emmanuel macron oui effectivement
c'est une école de la guerre je crois
que ça s'appelle comme ça
emmanuel macron aujourd'hui s'affrontent
effectivement une ultra violence une
ultra délinquants sur la visière soir à
avignon avec ce policier a été tué par
un dealer donc lancé dans l'ultra
violence absolue c'est le recul olivier
de l'état de droit
finalement alors on a vu gérald darmanin
allé hier soir toutes affaires cessantes
se rendre à avignon pour nous dire que
le pays était en pleurs que ce policier
est un héros national mais on va voir ce
qu'il va faire il ne suffit pas de faire
des tweets aujourd'hui ne suffit pas de
faire des
la ration il va falloir prendre le
problème à bras le corps parce qu'on
imagine bien que chez les policiers
si la consternation la tristesse et
surtout la peur de ce qui se trouve dans
les quartiers de ce qu'ils trouvent face
à ces trafics entre armée et là on est
vraiment dans l'état de droit qui est en
train de reculer de reculer de recul et
qui met encore notre sécurité
c'est des attaques c'est pas contre la
république c'est des attaques contre la
nation ses attaques contre la france
et si des gens finalement que 100 dans
des quartiers donc ils font les lois les
us et les coutumes et règlent leurs
comptes entre eux et maintenant ils
tirent sur les policiers a fait un petit
moment mais là je suis dire ce qui s'est
passé hier soir effectivement c'est
effrayant c'est inquiétant et ce qui est
encore plus inquiétant si à un moment
donné les chamallows de gérald harlin
une nouvelle fois qu'ils sundin sur
twitter et qui vient à avignon pour dire
que le pays est en pleurs on va voir
comment dire à darmanin va-t-il gérer ce
gros problème national
en un an vous l'avez dit olivier des
élections présidentielles aujourd'hui
c'est un problème qui dépasse largement
tous les clivages politiques
il va falloir mettre ça en place très
rapidement il va falloir frapper fort de
ce côté-là aussi bien en donnant des
moyens aux policiers sur cette
question-là extrêmement fondamental
extrêmement centrale sécurité à tous et
la réponse
la réponse nous disons la réponse
judiciaire également nous verrons ce que
me dira le mieux gardé des sceaux eric
dupond-moretti olivier alors le
gouvernement déterminé à lutter contre
les trafics de drogue mais fermement
opposé à la légation la légalisation du
cannabis
un sujet qui revient dans le débat mardi
le député françois michel lambert a fait
scandale il a brandi un joint à
l'assemblée nationale on a les images
regarder ce débat est donc crucial c'est
d'abord la santé de nos jeunes
et d'ailleurs le simple fait de montrer
ce gobelet pour m inquiéter je pourrais
être inquiété pour montrer la
légalisation du cannabis
s'il vous plaît faites de sang vous avez
des secondaires pourraient également
gelé des extensions l'envers il est un
homme simplement le désir serait un
débat sans l'instrumentalise passionnel
loin des émotions
un débat crucial pour nos jeunes nicolas
vidal en quelques mots votre réaction
ben moi j'ai trouvé ça c'est une
fanfaronnade du député l'embarras était
presque touchante hier olivier a bien
entendu et c'est la question politique
du rapport de l'état à la liga 6 à la
drogue finalement il y au trafic et à la
délinquance
on va il ya aussi la question sanitaire
sur la santé bien entendu mais
finalement quand on a ce genre de
propositions la semaine nationale
c'est le symbole de la danse du ventre
de deux députés finalement qui pensent
que l'état est incapable d'endiguer les
trafics que l'on a parlé pour le meurtre
l'assassinât du policier hier soir à
avignon et l'état devrait reculer donc
pour éviter de s'affronter de se
confronter aux trafics et mais on aurait
légalisé
effectivement ce député c'est compliqué
à comprendre ce genre d'intervention et
c'est qu'on n'est pas de l'histoire la
prohibition aujourd'hui c'est le une
nouvelle fois le recul de l'état de
droit
c'est vraiment ces questions là qui se
posent en arrière cours de cette
question sur le cannabis pile sur les
trafics et sur la délinquance bien
entendu c'est des questions qui sont
fondamentales centrale et qui vont
prendre plus en plus d'ampleur dc dc la
présidentielle merci beaucoup
nicolas votre édito politique c'est tous
les jeudis matin dans la matinale de rtl
france en attendant de vous retrouver la
semaine prochaine
on peut revoir cette élite aux
politiques sur les réseaux sociaux